cette vidéo est sponsorisé par kambly
une plateforme pour améliorer votre
anglais vous en parle en fin de vidéo
est une expérience que j'ai découvert il
ya quelques années et ça fait pas mal de
temps que j'ai envie de vous en parler
c'est celle du marche mal aux tests ou
plutôt du stanford marshmallow
expériment story times aussi walter
mischel décéda en 2018
regardez moi cette coupe de beau gosse
on a remis 1 73 et ce beau gosse et
psychologue et professeur à l'université
de stanford il décide de mener une étude
sur les enfants et les marshmallows
alors je me suis rendu compte que je
disais tout le temps les chamallows en
fait chamallow c'est le nom que haribo à
donner aux marches palau voilà sur une
boîte de haribo chamallows voilà accès
des marshmallows en fait pourquoi avoir
fait ça on sait pas nous dit plus un
chamallow dit marshmallow voilà on est
on dit pash a marre on nous a menti nous
a menti en plus de marques déposées et
tout donc c'est des marshmallows ou bien
des guimauves
mais c'est moins marrant à dire un
walter mischel ils sont pas les steaks
de tout ça lui c'est qu'on dit
marshmallow est en fait il a fait appel
à 50 enfants enfin je pense qu'il a
plutôt fait appel aux parents des
enfants qui ont été d'accord de trois à
cinq ans pour son expérience il en est
ensuite écarté 6 des enfants qui ne
comprenaient pas apparemment les
consignes voilà ça m'a fait rire cette
anecdote parce que je me suis mis à la
place des parents des enfants qui sont
fair tech de l'expérience en fait tu as
quand même le sol sur 59 ans n'est pas
foutu de comprendre les consignes les
enfants restant on leur dit la chose
suivante on leur présente un marshmallow
on leur dit voilà je te laisse ma part
au jeu sort un instant si quand je
reviens tu as pas manger smart malo je
tends fils un deuxième si tu le manges
avant que je revienne bateau aura qu'un
seul alors combien de temps
l'examinateur partait il partait 15
minutes donc si l'enfant réussissent à
attendre un quart d'heure et lé droit à
deux marches pablo cette étude c'est
donc une étude sur ce qu'on appelle la
gratification différé c'est votre
capacité à résister à la tentation
d'avoir une gratification immédiate dans
le but d'en avoir une plus tard en
général supérieures au niveau des
résultats il ya genre un enfant sur
trois qui
attendu les 15 minutes mais on s'en
fiche un petit peu c'est pas c'est pas
juste ce protocole la cas rendu
l'expérience célèbre bien que ce soit la
réelle torture pour les enfants ce qui a
rendu l'expérience célèbre c'est la
suite parce qu'en fait surtout les
enfants qui ont pu faire le test de
marshmallows on a fait un follow up
c'est à dire que l'on a fait des études
qui ont suivi en 88 ans 90 etc etc
on a remarqué qu'il y avait un lien
entre à quel point les enfants
attendaient pour le second marshmallow
et à quel point il ou elle réussissait
dans leur vie c'est à dire à quel point
vous avez de bonnes notes à quel point
il avait de bonnes relations à l'école à
quel point il avait réussi à gérer le
stress de l'adolescence et même par
exemple leurs notes aux tests et sa télé
tests et c'était aux etats unis c'est
des tests standardisés
il ya des foyers des qcm ce genre de
trucs qui permettent de rentrer la
lumière c'était d'ailleurs dans l'étude
on a aussi trouvé un lien avec l'obésité
plus on pouvait attendre pour le second
marshmallow et moi on avait de chances
d'être obèse l'idée de ces études
c'était donc de montrer l'importance
qu'avait cette gratification différé et
donc l'importance du self contrôle de la
discipline ce genre de chose pour la vie
à venir cette capacité elle est d'autant
plus importante maintenant ce que je
trouve qu'on vit dans une ère de la
gratification instantanée en tout cas
moi je vous je le vis comme ça la
plupart des applis sur lequel je passe
du temps fonctionne en gratification
instantanée alors instagram
je poste quelque chose gd l'aï tout de
suite
twitter que je sois soit en train de se
creuser sur le field sont en train de
tweets et dans tous les cas
gratification instantanée parce que soit
je vais avoir un article ou une vanne
que je trouve intéressante
soit je fais un tweet et je regardais
retweet etc c'est des choses dont on a
déjà parlé ensemble sur cette chaîne
mais on n'avait pas parlé du côté
instantané du truc enfin je crois
peut-être qu'on en a parlé en fait on a
tellement plus l'habitude de ça qui est
parfois quand on écrit à quelqu'un et
que la personne ne nous répond pas au
bout de quelques heures voire quelques
jours c'est hyper chaud vous parfois
même vexant ou alors vous êtes fait
poster voilà ça c'est un autre problème
ça arrive mais nous ont habitués à voir
les effets directs des choses genre
manière instantanée et savants suis
vachement rendu compte pas depuis que je
m'occupe de plantes en fête le budget
des plantes chez moi et cetera
où les effets sont beaucoup plus lents
en fait je suis hyper pressé que voilà
les nouvelles feuilles qui sortent la
gratification n'est pas instantané et
c'est ok on veut toujours tout tout de
suite et la plupart du temps on peut
l'obtenir et jusque internet a renforcé
sa cette instantanéité de ouf
maintenant je faisais la réflexion est
ce qu'un des grands marche mal aux tests
à l'échelle de la société
ce serait pas la crise du corona virus
au moment où je fais cette vidéo les
terrasses ouvre à nouveau ont des
confine voilà est-ce que c'est la bonne
chose à faire
est-ce que c'est pas trop tôt il n'y a
pas vraiment de consensus
battue est ce qu'être extrêmement
stricte pendant une période ne paraît
pas d'avoir une plus grosse
gratification derrière je pense par
exemple à wuhan qui a été hyper
drastique et ensuite quelques mois plus
tard c'était ça si je dézoom un petit
peu la chine n'a eu qu'une seule vague
je suis pas du tout en train de dire que
c'est ce qu'on aurait dû faire c'est ça
n'a rien à voir c'est situations très
différentes
une culture différente un régime
politique différent des frontières
différentes etc etc
c'est pas des situations comparables
mais je trouve ça quand même intéressant
de rapprocher le marshmallow test de la
gestion de crise du colis
il ya un parallèle que je trouvais cool
après le vrai marshmallow test c'est le
climat voilà est-ce qu'on serait capable
de se priver d'une gratification
instantanée pour une gratification
différé qui aura lieu dans des années je
l'espère maintenant ça c'est une version
de la réalité c'est la version nue
marche mal aux tests dont parlent tous
les ted tedx et c'est sur le sujet mais
y en a une autre qui date d'il ya peu de
temps
il ya une autre étude à laquelle a
participé michel ça fait que ça me fait
rire quand un michel tu participes à
l'étude
nickel cool ans michel y est c'est le
sait le chauffe du début je les réduit à
sa coupe de cheveux
je tombe dans les travers de ce que j'ai
dénoncé dans une vidéo il ya si
longtemps
mon dieu le serpent se mord la queue sur
cette propre chaîne il ya une autre
étude à laquelle a participé michel qui
étudie ce même groupe d'enfants mais qui
cette fois à la quarantaine d'années
michel est d'ailleurs décédé avant la
fin de l'étude
mais il avait capté leed l'idée c'est
qu'on se rend compte d'un truc chelou
on s'en rend compte que les enfants qui
avaient mangé le premier match mal au
plus vite ne sont pas plus pauvres en
moins bonne santé - bonne vie écrire ou
même avec une bonne scolarité
je cite whiting times nos statistiques
manipulées chips
oui eni a fait halte comme ce d'atouts
stade il précise qu'en par ailleurs si
vous avez qui fait mon accent c'est
peut-être grâce à kambly le sponsor de
cette vidéo on n'en parle plus tard on
en parle plus tard pas de souci alors
qu'est ce qui a changé entre ses études
et les études précédentes sûrement
l'occasion vous êtes en train de vous
poser l'humain est prévisible l'humain
est ce pas vous c'est l'humain qui est
prévisible est lancé pour la première
fois on a fait une analyse beaucoup plus
large des participants de l'étude
on a pris en compte par exemple leur
richesse leur dette leur crédit avec
d'autres indicateurs non financiers on a
fait aussi un indice qui mesure sa
capacité à autorégulé ses émotions voilà
on l'a fait à partir de 86 question on
leur a posé à 17 27 ans et 37 ans
d'ailleurs quand c'était 17 ans étaient
les parents qui répondait pour eux et
rien que cet indice en fait ils
expliquent la plupart des résultats des
études voilà et qu'on y ajoute ce truc
de marshmallows ou pas ne change pas
grand chose en fait pendant longtemps le
message de l'étude c'était pour que les
enfants soient responsables et qu'ils
aient du succès dans la vie il faut
qu'ils résistent le plus longtemps
possible à manger ce premier marche malo
est en fait c'est faux c'est quoi la
vérité alors je ne vais pas me risquer à
répondre à cette question est par contre
on peut parler de la suite des
événements avec le marshmallow test eh
bien figurez vous qu'il y a encore une
autre étude
plus récente qui brasse plus de monde et
qui a analysé plus de facteurs elle
s'appelle revisiting de marche proteste
concepteurs d'applications investigating
links between l'identification come from
what denken entre si j'étais rappeur je
pense que je l'aurais caser un moment le
nom de cette étude dans un rap ce
chocolat sonne ça devrais je prends bien
déjà ce qui change dans l'étude c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas pris genre un peu moins
de 90 enfants comme dans les études dont
on a parlé avant là ils ont pris plus de
900 hockey est ensuite très important la
première étude
elle est à stanford elle est dans la
maternelle qui se trouve dans le campus
de stanford
là ils sont allés chercher des enfants
qui viennent d'horizons beaucoup plus
variés il ya deux types d'ethnicité et à
d'autres types de classes sociales etc
qui sont mélangés dans cette étude
donc ça la rend beaucoup plus
intéressant et qu'est-ce qui nous montre
cette étude
elle nous montre qu'on peut
difficilement dire que retarder une
gratification nous permet d'avoir une
meilleure vie ce qui ne vit plus tôt
c'est que la capacité à attendre le
second marshmallow est étroitement lié
au background économique et social de
l'enfant et que c'est donc ça qui est
derrière le succès à long terme de
l'enfant par exemple on apprend que chez
les enfants dont la mère un diplôme
universitaire ceux qui ont attendu le
deuxième marche mal au nom pas de
meilleur score est athée ou non pas de
meilleurs comportements
d'après leur mère que ce qu'ils ont
mangé direct est pareil à linverse chez
ceux dont la mère n'avait pas de diplôme
universitaire si on enlève le facteur du
revenu du foyer et de l'environnement de
l'enfant à l'âge de trois ans d'ailleurs
dans les méthodes pour évaluer
l'environnement de l'enfant
ils comptaient par exemple le nombre de
livres qu'il y avait à la maison
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
moi j'en ai pas mal si c'est quelqu'un
est chaud enfin un enfant je pense avoir
vraiment un
un bon cadre je pense en tout cas en
terme de livres mais autre chose que
j'aime bien dans cette étude et qui m'a
vraiment touché c'est une explication de
pourquoi les enfants les plus pauvres
n'attendez pas le second marshmallow en
fait ils vivent dans un environnement où
un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras
il lui dans un environnement où si un
jour il ya un an j'ai foi en profiter
parce que demain ce sera fait pas le cas
c'est avec ce risque qui vivent à la
maison et même quand on leur promet des
choses parfois les parents ils peuvent
pas honorer leurs promesses par faute de
moyens dans le livre scarcity qu'on
pourrait traduire par pénurie
l'économiste de harvard sendhil mulaina
thann et le scientifique de princeton
eldar shafir parle de comment la
pauvreté peut pousser certaines
personnes à opter pour des choix court
terme plutôt que des choix long terme si
vous pensez que le premier match malo va
disparaître à quoi bon avoir le second
ces derniers résultats ne change pas le
fait que ça va résister à la
gratification immédiate
c'est important ne serait ce que pour la
programmation par exemple qui a un
concept qui repose vachement dessus
après je pense qu'il faut aussi modérer
ses résultats il va y avoir peut-être de
futures études ou là le but ça va être
de comprendre à quel point ces contextes
là nous détermine pas si vous vous
souvenez de la vidéo sur la criminalité
il en ressortait que en gros on avait
voilà ce patrimoine génétique là et qui
nous donnaient des prédispositions mais
qu'on pouvait dépasser ses
prédispositions là je pense qu'on est
dans une relation similaire
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu moi
je trouve ça intéressant vous en parler
maintenant ce serait que le parallèle
avec ce qu'on est en train de vivre en
ce moment et même la crise du courrier à
virus en général est hyper intéressant
moi c'est un marshmallow test à
l'échelle des pays flagrant quoi et
c'est hyper intéressant voilà de voir
comment chaque pays
arrêt j'ai dit
faire un an au test et encore une fois
chaque pays a des situations extrêmement
différentes un petit peu comme
finalement ce qui se dit dans cette
vidéo c'est que chaque chaque enfant
avait son contexte économico sociale à
la maison et c'est là la même manière
chaque pays en fait à son contexte est
fait en fonction de son contexte
sa situation sa culture voilà c'est
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça et
j'ai trouvé ça aussi cool d'aller plus
loin que la plupart des ressources qu'on
peut trouver sur le sujet sur le match
mal aux tests qui en fait non ne
prennent pas en fait les dernières
études en compte les toutes dernières
études mais parce que l on voit là ils
ont que trois ans genre donc sage que
c'est intéressant à faire
la plupart de ceux contenus la façon il
est en anglais et c'est peut-être pour
ça que j'ai envie de vous parler du
sponsor du jour kambly c'est une
plateforme qui permet de rentrer en
relation directement avec des tuteurs
anglophone donc l'idée c'est d'améliorer
votre anglais notamment conversationnel
avec des tuteurs qui ont tous le point
commun d'être vraiment bilingue jour si
moi je voulais twitter je pourrais pas
être tout vous connaissez l'importance
de parler anglais - ne serait ce que
pour faire cette vidéo et la plupart des
vidéos d'ailleurs que je fais sur cette
chaîne quasiment tout le contenu que je
consomme pour l'afer est en anglais vous
avez plein de fonctionnalités hyper cool
par exemple les prendre un tuteur en
fonction de son accent 1 par exemple la
se voulait préparer un voyage en irlande
l'accent irlandais voilà ça peut être
intéressant s'accrocher donc pourquoi
pas pareil l'accent australien l'accent
anglais etc
vous pouvez aussi répété si vous avez
des zorro ou des présentations orales en
anglais kambly peut servir aussi à ça
vous est aussi des thématiques
conversationnel vous pouvez parler je
sais pas vraiment de d'environnement de
parentalité de série voilà il ya plein
de thématiques au choix de conversation
si vous voulez vous améliorez sur un
sujet de conversation
si vous n'avez toujours pas essayer
kambly ou pouvez l'essayer gratuitement
avec le code promo qui s'affiche ici et
vous avez aussi une réduction de 40% sur
les abonnements de 12 mois si vous
voulez faire un truc vraiment longue
durée l'intégrer dans votre routine et
cetera
ce que je conseille toujours de faire
quand on apprend une nouvelle langue ou
en tout cas quand on s'entraîne
qu'on veut s'améliorer sur une langue
spécifique merci à eux de soutenir la
chaîne cette année c'est pas la première
vidéo qui sponsorise et c'est un plaisir
d'avoir des sponsors qui accompagne sur
la durée c'est toujours plus pratique et
donc merci kambly de soutenir la chaîne
et voilà vraiment je vous invite à aller
voir ce qu'ils font aller vous inscrire
sur le site à faire une séance une
séance de tests etc
ce qui parfois l'anglais seront vite si
vous partez en voyage vous serez
toujours plus à l'aise en ayant pratiqué
un petit peu encore merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas on se retrouve tous les
mardis à 22h sur twitch hier soir on
était sûr twitch avec charles villa et
voilà on a passé les 50000 followers sur
twitter
donc c'est fou et hier soit en live on a
atteint un pic à 3700 personnes
incroyables c'est incroyable donc c'est
la folie tout je m'éclate et aussi le
mercredi soir jeu peut-être dès qu'elle
est un petit peu l'horaire parce que
pour profiter un petit peu moi aussi
j'ai le droit de sortir le terrasse tout
ça pourquoi pas là je peux me coiffe
tout comme ça voilà love peace pour la
2eme horaire du mercredi je vous tiens
au jus vous tient au jus sur les réseaux
suivez moi sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur instagram sur twitter etc star je
vous en parle love peace
ciao